عمليه اقتحام التي قام بها قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله في نابلس تحديدا
وذلك منذ حوالي ساعتين او ثلاث وقتلها
لعدد من الفلسطينيين خمسه فلسطين استشهدوا
45 اخرون اصيبوا بعض حالاتهم حرجه في هذه
العمليه منهم من كان يعني
مواطنين طبعا كانوا عزل اصيبوا او
استشهدوا
ضمنهم ايضا
مواطنين الفلسطينيين كان محاصرين ومطاردين
من قبل قوات الاحتلال في احد البيوت في
البلده القديمه في نابلس وهما حسام سليم
محمد الجنيري الذي لديه قتلتهم قوه
الاحتلال قبل ان تنسحب من بلده القديمه لا
ندري ان كانت قوه احتلال ما زالت موجوده
في نابلس ام انسحبت نهائيه من المدينه
لهذا سنعود اخرى الى وليد العمري من رام
الله مدير مكتبه الجزيره طبعا ليطلعنا على
جديد الموقف الميداني
وعن ايضا انتشار قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في المدينه ان كانت مازالت موجوده او
غادرت وليد
قوات الاحتلال انسحبت من البلده القديمه
لكنها ما زالت في اطراف المدينه وهي مدينه
كبيره وعلى مداخلها لتامين انسحاب باقي
قواتها قوات الاحتلال دخلت على دفعتين
اساسيتين
تقديرات شهود العيان انه اكثر من 50 اليه
مدرعه مدعمه بالمسيرات وكذلك طائرات
الاباتشي وسبقتها ايضا مجموعات مما يعرف
بكوماندوز المستعربين وهي عناصر من الشباك
المخابرات العامه وعناصر عسكريه تتخفى
بالزي المدني كانت قد تسللت الى تلك
المنطقه وقامت بهذا الهجوم على البيت الذي
تواجد فيه
الشهيدين الذين قالت انها استهدفتهما بشكل
خاص لكن قبل ذلك اطلقت قذائف مضاده للدروع
على هذا البيت ثم وقعت اشتباكات كبيره
بعضها مسلح داخل البلده القديمه واخرى
كانت مع مواطنين
المحتجين خارج البلده القديمه التي سدت
قوات الاحتلال منافذها بمدرعات مصفحه
ومنعت احد من الاقتراب وكانت تطلق النيران
ايضا على المحتجين لذلك عدد الشهداء هو
خمسه وعدد الجرحى 45 بينهم سبعه في حاله
الخطر بالاضافه لنحو 250 هم اصيبوا بحالات
اختناقهم وجروح خفيفه من الاعيرات
المطاطيه وقنابل الغاز للدموع ما يمكن
الاشاره اليه في هذا السياق انه من باب
الخطا التعامل مع ما يجري وكانه مواجهه
بين جيشين او بين قوتين عسكريتين هناك جيش
هائل يملك كافه المعدات والاسلحه
بعضها ومعظمها من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واسرائيل وهناك عشبان فلسطينيين
مقاومين بعضهم مسلح وبعضهم غير مسلح
وبعضهم غير مدرب اصلا لذلك تقع في اوساطهم
هذه الاعداد الكبيره من الاصابات والشهداء
وما جرى في نابلس هو حلقه جديده وان جاء
بهدف ربما ليخدم سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه وهي حكومه تتشكل من
احزاب اقصى اليمين المتطرف والعنصري والتي
توصف حتى اسرائيليا بانها حكومه ابرتهايد
او حكومه حكومه مستوطنين كما سماها البعض
حكومه يهودا
لديها هذا الهدف هدف صعيد عمليه القتل هي
الان تريد ان تصرف نظر المعارضين في
اسرائيل لسياستها الانقلابيه على الدستور
كما يسمونها والازمه الاقتصاديه المتفاقمه
تريد ان تصرفها الى اهتمام ان يصب
باهتمامهم على القضايا الامنيه هناك حاليا
يقومون بسن قوانين جديده اثنان احدهما
التغلب على قرارات المحكمه العليا بمعنى
تحييدها نهائيا ولا تعد قراراتها صالحه لا
تحمي حتى المواطن الاسرائيلي والاخر وهو
سن قانون اعدام ضد الاسرار الفلسطينيين
المدانيين بقتل يهود كما ياتي في واضح
بانها تصعيد بالاضافه الى عمليات تصعيد
سياسه هدم المنازل هذا كله يضع علامه سؤال
كبيره على ما يحمله المستقبل القريب من
نذر لانفجار يحذر منه كثيرون يحذر منه
ايضا مسؤولون عسكريون كبار اسرائيليون لان
سياسه قاده الحكومه الحاليه
واهتمام نتنياهو بالافلات من التهم التي
تلاحقه حسب ما يقوله معارضوه هذا كله
يحاول ان يحول الموضوع الى الموضوع الامني
الذي يجمع عليه معظم الاسرائيليين